when you're reviewing a movie that a
potential client has sent you are you
watching the whole movie
yeah if I
unless I
it isn't very good
yeah so you have a limit yo yeah oh yeah
um
yeah if I if I enjoy it I I watch it all
the way through and
um and then if I if I'm hired I usually
watch it again before I start talking
about it
um because usually there's a few weeks
between that moment and when I actually
start doing it so I'm usually watching
my films twice
um
and um
but yeah I think that's you know there
are a lot of films though where you just
kind of like I can't sell it you know
like why why why you know you know
within 10 minutes there are lots of out
of focus stuff for the acting's really
bad or there's a lot of bad movies
um out there that no one ever sees
that uh that I I get to watch a little
bit of
that was my next question yeah what
would make you turn it off after I we
have five minutes but okay let's say 10
minutes so you give it do you have a
rule like I'll give it a certain amount
of time and then yeah it's it's more
instinctive it's a more
um
it's um
I I don't I don't think anybody out of
the circle of friends of the person who
made the movie would doubt why I got out
like it's that you know there's a lot of
um well I should say though there's also
stuff I just don't think there's a home
for
and if it's like
um you know the hardest category is is
drama without names
um and if you found an interesting way
to tell the story then
then and it works and we think there's a
home for it then great but
um that I find is probably the hardest
to pull off and if if you haven't like
grabbed me in the first 10 minutes
you're probably not a grab you know
distributor who has less patience than
me
um and so I probably can't help you you
know but I think I I mean I think I
probably
that's for some films but there are some
films I watch all the way through and
then make that same decision that like
well I got there but it was torturous
right like or or in some way I just
couldn't I just don't feel like I could
help them
and what do you tell filmmakers that
fall into that category
the truth
yeah I have to you know I
um without being mean about it you know
with just saying hey I thank you for
sharing the movie
um it's not it's not right for me
um I just don't feel like I could sell
it and maybe there's someone out there
for you and here maybe give them some
other people
um that you know there's a there's a
website out there with a bunch of
producer reps on it and I usually say
you know check out that and maybe
there's another way for you or in some
some people are also very nice it also
especially if they're very nice people
and they made a bad movie that's really
hard and so I'll even get on the phone
with them and talk to them about
self-distribution and what they maybe
could do you know themselves that might
be the best option because I don't think
that there's a distributor would take it
on so I'll have that conversation with
people
um once in a while
are there individuals who will fight you
on it and say you didn't give it a
chance or they'll kind of like negate
your issues that you have with it yeah
but not often
yeah there have been
get all types of people
for sure I've had some movies I've
watched you know a couple movies because
I've watched thousands of movies
um
I've had a couple movies where I watched
the film and I really wondered about the
sanity of the person who made the movie
not a good way like a razor head or
something like that but in a really
disturbing like what is this weird thing
that someone sent me and I don't want to
talk to them at all that's happened a
couple times but that's pretty you know
and I've had a couple you know I've had
a few people who are like
um who make the pitch that like you know
this is better you think I'm like well
then I'm sure you'll find a home
is it hard for you to tell people no
no
I am
it's part of the job I think I think
it's to be honest and
um my mission in general is to help
filmmakers
um
get the best possible distribution
and if I extend that to everyone even to
not my clients
um and the best message for them is you
should distribute this yourself because
I don't think a distributor will take it
on I think if
I've got an obligation to share that
message and
it's much it's actually easier than
than saying oh it's really good but I
can I don't know how to make stuff up I
don't know I wouldn't know how to how to
how to fake that well in some ways you
might be helping them because then if
they're getting the same notes then if
they make another project they'll try to
correct right yeah yeah 100 percent
would you rather a filmmaker send you
their trailer or the entire film
um the whole film I like to see the
whole thing
um
usually
almost I don't know if I've ever turned
a film down off of a trailer
I don't think I have and quite often
people will send me a trailer
when they when they reach out to me
um and then I'll say hey looks good can
I see the whole movie but I almost like
to see the whole thing before I talk to
someone as well so I get a feeling for
what they have sometimes people want to
talk ahead of time and I just feel it's
a bit of a waste of time because
yeah I don't know if I know if I can
help you yet I don't know what to tell
you yet
and then it becomes just a free tutorial
you know like about the business where I
don't mind that but I prefer to be
afterwards let's do it in one shot
rather than several so
do you have a preferred method for for
watching something or do you have it
just playing on another screen
um I throw up I've uh I most people send
vimeulinks and I usually throw them up
on my big screen TV to watch them
um I have a little quirk in that I like
to
um
when I go to buyers with films
um if we're not pushing them to a
theater it's it's South by Southwest or
um
if we're just sharing it with them
directly there are some Distributors I
like to uh to send a Blu-ray as opposed
to a video link
um
not all of them will do it some would
prefer to leave me a link but there are
some that are open to getting my Blu-ray
and then I prefer that a little bit
because I'm forcing them to watch it on
something bigger than than
um than their phone because I know some
of them do I haven't seen it personally
that someone watched it on their phone
but given that you can I imagine that
like you know if you're in Acquisitions
executive and you've got five films to
watch that day and you're at lunch you
might pop one on your phone
um just to get just to get through it
um
and then you know it's not that's not
the most illegitimate thing to do given
that if you're a straight to digital
Distributors lots of people watching
these things on small screens
um so they may feel like they can but I
just feel like in general if I'm trying
to like
get someone to take on a movie I'm
usually trying to encourage them to
watch on something bigger
um just so they have a better experience
than than something like an iPad you
know
you mentioned that you occasionally will
watch a string of bad movies here and
there how many movies do you feel like
you have to go through to get to one
that really piques your interest
it's probably well first of all I the
number of clients come to me from
referrals
um either from agencies because they
think hey it's too small for for us and
they recommend me
and they usually don't recommend me
unless it's someone they think there's a
possibility of me taking it on
um I get referrals from from just kind
of being out there in the world for a
long time
um
and so the referral the the
the um the rate of which I take films on
for referrals is quite High
um because those have been curated to a
certain degree
um
and there's
but from the the cold one so was it
coming cold to me I probably have to
watch 10 to find one
that I feel like I can work on
um
it's about that ratio
how do you handle it when a producer
comes to you and they expect to make
let's say a million dollars off a film
with a half a million dollar budget
so I'm always measuring expectations
with
potential clients
um because
um
I don't really want to work with someone
that that expects something that's not
going to happen
um
especially if they're gonna
blame me for it after the fact right
like hey I I told you I needed to get a
million dollars and you didn't get a
million dollars
um so I'm always very careful to kind of
explain
how much films in general make in the
marketplace what the percentage chances
are for getting a deal with a streamer
what the percentage chances are for
getting with one of these all rights
Distributors and what they do
and then even once you get that deal
because there's a it's never 100 because
it's subjective and we don't know
um
then you know what here's the range of
Revenue you could potentially get and
they have to be comfortable with that
um
because I'm gonna I'm gonna tell them
what the ranger revenue is and so
usually
um there have been cases where it got
past me and I didn't like somehow we
didn't communicate about the the number
that they thought they were going to get
and then after the fact they're like I
thought this would make this and I'm
like I don't know how you would have
thought that we went through all this
you know discussion about why that's not
possible
um
and like you said some people just
Harbor that thing in the back of my wall
of mine will be different I don't care
what he's saying and he's still going to
do a good job and still make me money
um but then it you know but I try not to
get into situations
is there a litmus test that you have for
expectations or you can just try to be
as clear as you can you have your own
contracts you have emails
and yeah I mean usually I upright I'm
asking them where they you know what
their goals are and what their but you
know what their hopes are
um I'd say most people come off with
pre-reasonable hopes it's pretty unusual
for someone to be pretty you know like
oh this is for Netflix and just be no
and just knowing that and being totally
wrong
um that's unusual most people have
I find a certain level of Education of
the business that they know that it's
not you know they know what it is to a
certain degree
um
so I'm helped a little bit by that but
you know I definitely that's part of the
conversation every single time
um I make it a part of the conversations
part of what I when I when we're
emailing back and forth to start that's
part of my questionnaire is like what
you know what are your expectations what
do you hope for are just also usually
ask are there any disturbs you don't
like
um to get out from them the prejudices
that they might have from the the the
um from the internet and you know
they've heard other Distributors being
bashed on and what they think so I can
dispel those myths to a certain degree
as well
um but yeah those
yeah I have to you know I have to feel
like the client isn't crazy and I have
to feel like they've got
hopes but reasonable expectations at the
same time
I like that so you have a questionnaire
what like 20 questions not even not even
like five questions oh I see okay a lot
of there's more things come out of that
but yes the basic ones are
um what are your expectations for the
film what are the Distributors you don't
you're specifically hoping for are there
any Distributors you particularly don't
want to be with
um what do you what are your Festival
aspirations those are the main ones
has ever been a situation where you
absolutely love the film but you've
decided not to take it on no
um if I love a film I want to take it on
period even if I think it's going to be
hard
um as long as
even if I think it's not likely to get
distribution
as long as the filmmaker understands
that it's not likely to get distribution
and I'm going to work as hard as I can
to get a distribution
that being said I don't come across any
films that I don't think can get a
certain level of distribution
like for me like I really don't work on
Films unless
it's gonna get a deal with an all-rise
distributor that will do it properly and
get it on the various digital platforms
I may love it and hope that it gets
better than that and the theatrical or a
Netflix deal you know something bigger
but not think it's gonna but the odds
are against it
um but I just needed the filmmaker to be
clear about
that but if I think a film isn't going
to get
it's just I don't know they've ever seen
a film that I loved
that I didn't think would get at least
that level of distribution
I don't think that's happened